[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
NANCY KANWISHER: So this
is the line-up for today.
We're going to be talking
about language today
and on Wednesday.
But I want to start
with something
that I gave very short shrift
at the end of lecture last time.
And I'm going to
give it short shrift
again, but in a
slightly different way.
You'll need this for the
reading, which hopefully you've
already tried, started.
Representational
similarity analysis
is subtle and rich
and interesting.
And it's taken me
years of revisiting
it to get its full force.
So just keep going at it and
hopefully every time you'll
get it a little better.
So let me try another
brief version of this.
So representational
similarity analysis
is like a generalized case
of multiple voxel pattern
analysis that applies
to other methods
and characterizes a
bigger conceptual space.
So to remind you, multiple
voxel pattern analysis
with functional MRI
is this business where
you split your data in half.
So you have one
set of scans where
people are looking at, say, dogs
and another set where they're
looking at cats, and a whole
other separate replication
where they're looking
at dogs and cats.
You look at the
pattern of response
across voxels in each of those
four conditions, dog 1, dog
2, cat 1, cat 2.
And you ask if the pattern
is more similar for the two
different splits of the
data in the same condition,
dog 1, dog 2, and cat 1, cat
2, the diagonal here, than
in the two cases where they're
different, dogs to cats.
Everybody remember that?
If you're having trouble with
this, come see me or the TAs.
That's not good.
So now, that's MVPA.
And you can use that to ask
of a given region of interest
in the brain or the whole brain,
if the pattern of response
in that region can
distinguish between class A
and Class B. That's
what it's good for.
So that's worth knowing,
but it's impoverished.
It's binary.
I mean, cats versus dogs.
It's a dopey example I choose.
But whatever you choose, it's
just going to be two things.
It only takes you so far
in characterizing what's
represented in that region.
You can make it richer if
you force it to generalize.
So if these two are a smaller
size and a different viewpoint
from those, and it
still works, then we
show that there's generality.
Train on one kind of condition,
test on a slightly different
version of them.
That tests the invariants.
That's richer and
more interesting.
But even so, it's limited.
So representational
similarity analysis
is a bigger, richer way of
characterizing representations
by looking at the
pattern of response
across multiple conditions, not
just two and their variations.
So instead of
something like this,
we'd have something like
this with a whole bunch
of different stimuli
or conditions
that we scan people on.
And then we look at all
the pairwise combinations--
how similar is dog to
cat, how similar is it
to pig or horse or table
or chair or whatever.
So then we have all of
these pairwise similarities,
which gives us a richer idea
of what's going on there.
And so now we don't have to
choose a binary classification
in there.
We can look at
that entire space.
We can think of this
whole space as our proxy
for what is represented in
that region of the brain.
So now that's cool.
So everybody get the
gist of how this set
of pairwise similarities
in a region of the brain
is a richer idea of what's
going on in that region
and what it cares about?
Everybody got that?
Now, chunk that
matrix as one thing.
That's a representation
of what's represented
in this part of the brain.
But now we can take that
unit and we can say,
we can do the same thing on a
totally different kind of data.
So here's what we just did.
Here's like some region
of the brain, voxels.
We can do the same
thing in behavior.
Now we can say,
OK, you rate for me
how similar is a dog to a cat
on a scale from one to 10.
I don't know, six or something.
How similar is a cat to a pig?
Four, I don't know.
You can see, you imagine you
get some similarity space.
You could just
get people to rate
them and you could make
a whole new matrix here.
Now you're characterizing
your conceptual space
over those same
items behaviorally
by asking people how
similar each thing are.
Here, we're comparing
similarity of patterns
of responses across voxels.
Here, we're doing it by
asking how similar it
seems to people behaviorally.
Everybody get how that's a
similar kind of enterprise?
Or, we could record from
neurons in monkey brains
and show them the same pictures.
And just look at the
response across, say,
100 neurons in the monkey brain
to a dog and a cat and a pig
and so forth.
And then we could,
ask how similar
is a response across neurons
in the monkey to each pair
of stimuli, just as we did that
across each pair of stimuli
across voxels.
Everybody got that?
So in each case, we're
getting a matrix like this.
Now, we can do the
totally cool-- oh, sorry,
we're not quite yet.
We can also do that not
just on functional MRI
voxels in the whole
brain or in one region,
but we can make
separate matrices.
These are obviously
all fake data.
I didn't take the trouble
to make different matrices
for each, right.
But we can make
different matrices
for different
regions of interest
in the brain, one for each.
Voxels here, what's their
pairwise set of similarities
across those stimuli?
Voxels over here, what's their
pairwise set of similarities?
Now, we can correlate these
matrices to each other.
So we can say, for
example, we had
a bunch of people do
ratings and give us
their behavioral similarities
based over these stimuli.
And then we looked in
some region of the brain
and got the brain's similarity
space and their responses
across voxels.
How similar are
those to each other?
So it's like we've
moved up a level.
Each matrix is a
set of correlations
between each pair of stimuli.
But then once we have
that set of correlations,
we can take the whole matrix and
correlate it to another matrix.
This would be a way of asking
in some region of the brain
how well does the representation
in this chunk of brain match
people's subjective impression
of that similarity space
when you ask them about it.
Everybody see how that's a
way to ask that question?
We can also relate
functional MRI voxels
to neurophysiology
responses across neurons.
We can ask how
similar is your FFAs--
let's not take the FFA--
your LO that likes object
shape, how similar is its shape
space in your brain
measured with functional MRI
to shape space in this
part of the monkey's brain
registered with neurophysiology.
It's pretty cosmic, right.
We're asking if the monkey
sees the world the same way you
do, in a sense, for this
method, by using these matrices
and asking how similar they
are across species and methods.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So are the function
for [INAUDIBLE] similarity.
All of them are the same or?
NANCY KANWISHER: You could
do whatever you like.
So you can do garden
variety functional MRI
like we've been talking about
in here just like the Haxby
thing from 2001.
That's when it all
started, right.
Just get a vector across
voxels for one condition,
a vector across voxels
for the two condition,
and correlate them.
You can do that in
responses across neurons.
But you can also do
more exotic things.
You can train a linear
classifier on a bunch of voxels
and say, how well can it
decode the response to pig
to the response to dog.
And you can put that
number in that cell.
So you can do it different
ways, any measure of similarity.
Or, very confusingly,
there's an increasing trend
to talk about dissimilarity,
not similarity,
by subtracting the
r values from 1.
I find that annoying, but
it's all over the literature.
And who cares whether it's
similarity or dissimilarity.
Doesn't really matter.
They're both ways of collecting
a representational space.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Are there any
caveats into the [INAUDIBLE]
that we should be
available, since this
is like a correlation
of coordination.
NANCY KANWISHER: Oh, a million.
You're supposed to
Fisher transform it
and do all that garbage.
And we're not
discussing that in here.
I'm just trying to
give you the idea.
I don't mean to be dismissive.
I'm skipping over
all of that stuff
to just give you the
gist of the idea.
For purposes in this class,
you could just eyeball
that and that.
And you'd say, oh,
they're really ident--
no, they're not identical.
I guess, I did switch it.
I did switch a few of them, oh.
OK, anyway, whatever.
For purposes in this class,
you could just eyeball them.
Mathematically,
an r-value-- we're
leaving out all the details.
Yeah, OK.
And, of course, we
can compare behavior
in a person to physiology in a
monkey, or behavior in a monkey
to physiology in a monkey.
And here's one thing you
need for the reading.
I hope it didn't
already stump you.
It's in a tiny part
of one of the figures.
We could make up a hypothesis
of what's represented here.
We might say, hey, consider
this patch of brain.
Maybe it represents the
animate/inanimate distinction.
In the ideal case,
that would mean all
it knows is animals
versus non animals.
And so that would
mean this should
be the representational
similarity space.
If these are all the
animals, they're all
exactly the same as each other.
All the non-animals are
the same as each other.
But any animal and any
non-animal are different.
So this is a hypothesized
similarity space
of our guess of
what's represented
in a region, a model
of what we think
is represented in a region.
And we can correlate that
to any of these matrices
to ask whether our hypothesis
of what's in there is right.
Does that make sense?
OK.
So why is that so-- oh, this
whole thing so totally cool?
It enables us to compare
representational spaces
across regions of
interest in the brain--
the FFA to the PPA, do they
have similar representational
spaces--
across subject
groups-- this batch
of subjects and that
batch of subjects--
without having to align voxels.
We're not aligning voxels.
We've left voxels behind.
We're only using these matrices.
We can do it across
species, across methods,
and across hypothesized
models of what we
think is going on, like that.
So more generally, this
probes representations
in a richer way.
We don't need to have just
10 or whatever I put there.
We could have, if we keep
subjects in the scanner long
enough, or monkeys in
the lab long enough,
we can get hundreds of stimuli
and really characterize
a rich space.
And we're looking at not just
two discriminations, but lots.
The key requirement for
representational similarity
analysis, to be able to
do all this cool stuff,
is the axes need to be the same.
So the stimuli that you're
getting the similarity of
need to be the same in
the person doing behavior,
the person doing MRI, the monkey
doing physiology, the model.
If the axes are not
the same, then there's
no way to correlate
the matrices.
Make sense?
We'll keep coming at
this again and again.
You'll see it in the
paper for tomorrow night.
And we'll come at it again
in class on Wednesday.
So that was all catch-up.
So today, we are going
to talk about language.
And let's start by reflecting
on what an amazing thing
language is.
So right now, there's a
miraculous thing going on.
I'm taking some weird, abstract,
hard-to-grasp, even for me,
ideas someplace in my head--
god knows where,
somewhere in there--
and I'm trying to
take those ideas
and translate them into this
bunch of noises coming out
my mouth.
That's already
pretty astonishing.
Like, what?
What does that idea look like?
Who the hell knows?
How do you take an
abstract idea and turn it
into a string of sounds?
That's wild.
Nobody really knows
pretty much a damn thing
about how that works,
fascinating mystery.
But then that bunch
of noises is going
through the air and producing,
let's hope, pretty similar
ideas in your head.
Wow.
We do this all day every day.
Big deal.
But it's astonishing.
It's just astonishing
that that works at all.
So that's the
essence of language.
That's why it's so cool.
And let's think about how we're
going to think about this.
So the first thing to note is
language is universally human.
All neurologically intact
humans have language.
There are about 7,000
languages in the world.
Sadly, this number is
shrinking all the time.
They are all richly expressive,
including sign languages.
There are no kind of
impoverished languages
that don't capture
the full richness
of expressible human experience.
They're all equally rich.
Language is uniquely human.
Yes, chimps and
parrots can accomplish
all kinds of cool things,
especially if you train them
extensively.
But what they have is not
anything really like language.
And to give you a
vivid sense of this,
let's look at Chaser,
the Border Collie.
And what I want you to think
about as you look at this
little video of Chaser the
Border Collie is what is
the difference between
your language abilities
and Chaser's.
Chaser is pretty
damned impressive,
but you are more impressive.
So watch it and enjoy
and think about how it's
different from what you do.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- Some of us burst with
pride if our dogs can respond
to two or three commands.
But what if we haven't
begun to understand
the possibilities of what the
animal mind can really do?
Our friend, astrophysicist
Neil deGrasse Tyson,
is host of Nova Science Now.
And he brings us big
news from the frontier.
- Walk up, walk up, walk up.
- Meet Chaser, beloved
six-year-old Border Collie
of Psychology
Professor John Pilley.
- Good girl.
She was born to live in
the Scottish mountains--
Chase, toe, toe, toe--
and herd sheep.
Go, go.
- John has taught chaser
to tend an extremely large.
if unconventional
herd, of 1,000 toys.
And she knows the name of
every single one of these?
- I hope.
- I find this hard to believe,
so I test Chaser's memory
with a random sampling.
Chaser, find Inky.
Well, she got one right.
Find Seal.
Whoa, and that one too.
In fact, she got all nine right.
But what about a new toy
she's never seen or heard
the name of?
Chaser's never seen Darwin,
hasn't even ever heard the name
Darwin.
So we're going to see if she
picks out Darwin by inference.
Find Darwin.
I have to ask her again.
OK, Chaser, Chaser, Chaser,
Chaser, find Darwin.
(EXCITEDLY) Darwin!
He's got Darwin!
She did it.
Chaser's never seen
that doll before,
yet she settled on the one toy
she didn't know by deduction.
It's similar to the way
children learn language.
But how does Chaser's ability
compare with other species?
Besides us, chimps and bonobos
are the animal kingdom's
top linguists, capable of
learning sign language,
but very slowly.
They can solve some
sophisticated problems,
but they don't always pay
close attention to humans.
- Is he coming?
- When I see my dog, my
dog wants me to be around.
Whereas a bonobo and
chimpanzee, they need me.
They're basically like,
hey, you got any food.
Can I get any food off of you?
They're not interested
in making me happy.
- Since dogs do
like to please us,
that humans need to find a way
to tap the potential in all
of our dogs.
OK, put it in the tub.
And dogs like Chaser
are just waiting for us
to discover all
that they can do.
[GRUNTS] Smart dog.
- And Neil deGrasse
Tyson is here
with the astonishing
Chaser here.
Tell me what you learned about
animal behavior and child
behavior.
- Who would have
thought that the animals
are capable of this much
display of intellect.
I think we like thinking of
humans as top of some ladder
and don't even imagine
that other animals could
even approximate what we do.
- All right, I think
we all want to see.
- You want the demo.
- Can we do it?
- A demo of this.
- Do you think we can it.
- Sure.
We can try it.
- This is so astounding.
Can we take away the stool.
- Sure.
Let's try this.
- We'll give it a try.
[INAUDIBLE]
Thanks.
All right, so we get down?
- Let's get down on dog level.
That's always better.
- All right, [INAUDIBLE].
- OK, Chaser, find Goose.
[STUFFED TOY SQUEALING]
- OK.
- Can I do this one?
- You can do this one.
- Chaser, Chaser, find ABC.
ABC-- you did it!
We thank you.
And we want everyone to know
that it's a truly remarkable
NOVA tonight.
Four wheels reporting tonight
on NOVA Science Now on PBS.
And to you and your brilliant
dogs at home, goodnight.
[END PLAYBACK]
NANCY KANWISHER: OK.
She's a very good girl.
And she knows a lot of nouns,
right, 1,000 nouns, apparently.
But what can't she do
that you guys can do?
Is this language?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: It's word
identification.
It's not language.
You modify actions
[INAUDIBLE] language
to be able to put verbs
and nouns together.
NANCY KANWISHER: That's good--
verbs and nouns together.
What else?
Yeah, [INAUDIBLE]?
AUDIENCE: It's
fortification of things.
If they were like a bigger
ABC and a smaller ABC
type of thing, that distinction
wouldn't be possible.
NANCY KANWISHER: Alex the
Parrot can do that one.
I don't have the
video of Alex, and I
don't want to get
too hung up on this,
but some animals can
do that kind of stuff.
What else?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Yeah,
it's probably closer
to like sound
identification. like,
how I can identify the sound of
a train or the sound of a car.
NANCY KANWISHER: So just
some rudimentary thing,
like, visual form and sound.
How about when she found Darwin?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
NANCY KANWISHER: Sorry?
AUDIENCE: Wasn't that case
just, like you said, deduction?
It was just like, it
wasn't any of the words.
NANCY KANWISHER: That's
right, that's right.
But that's pretty
impressive, isn't it?
Turns out, kids use that rule
too in learning language.
It's a whole set
of studies of how
kids use rules to try to figure
out what people are referring
to when they learn novel words.
And that's one of the
things that kids use.
If there's a thing
here that I don't know
and somebody's saying a
sound here I don't know,
that thing probably
goes with the sound.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: I was about to say,
I took 9.85 last semester.
We talked about like
an exact experiment
where kids were able to
learn the words of toys
that were like
not English words,
but like "dax" and stuff.
But then when they were
given like a new object,
they would be able to
identify it as different.
NANCY KANWISHER: Exactly.
It's called mutual exclusivity.
And that's exactly what
Chaser is showing here.
OK, so pretty
impressive, but not fully
language, more like
memorizing a bunch of nouns
plus mutual exclusivity plus
some other stuff, maybe.
She certainly can't understand
who did what to who and why.
This is not even
in the ballpark.
This is the essence of what
we talk to each other about is
this kind of stuff, all kinds
of complicated relationships
between different concepts that
we communicate in language.
So animals in-- not
just taught English,
but animals in their
natural environments
communicate in rich and
detailed ways with each other.
But usually in each case,
about a very restricted domain.
What kind of danger is around?
What kind of food
source is around?
Those basic kinds
of narrow things
that are of survival
value, those
are the things that animal
communication systems usually
deal with.
And in contrast,
human languages are
open-ended and compositional.
Compositional means
that we combine
words to say new things,
things no human being
has ever said before.
So that you don't
see in animals.
So what is language cognitively?
That is, what do you have
to know to know a language?
Bunch of basic things.
One is phonology, the
sounds of language.
We've talked about this a bit in
the case of speech perception.
Just hearing the difference
between a ba and a pa,
or seeing the
equivalent gesture.
American Sign Language
is a fully expressive
natural language.
And there the phonemes
are different pieces
of hand movements rather
than sounds, but function
as phonemes all the same.
And we talked about a
region of the brain that
responds very specifically
to speech sounds in humans.
Moving up into the
language system,
that's just an input system--
and by the way, we also talked
about the visual word form
area, a very recent addition to
the input system in language.
But that's only a few
thousand years old.
It's really phonology that's the
native form of language that's
been around for tens, if
not hundreds, of thousands
of years in human evolution.
So semantics, we need
to know what words mean.
That's lexical semantics.
But we also need
to know how meaning
arises when words go together.
And related to how
words go together,
we need to know about
the syntax of a language.
That is, the structure
or grammar of a language.
And so each language
has a set of rules
about how you string words
together in that language.
And usually central to that--
it's not the only thing,
but a central part of
that-- is word order.
And that whole set of rules
for how you string together
words, following
word order rules,
determines the meaning
of the string of words.
For example, shark bites man is
different than man bites shark.
And that just comes
out of the syntax
that we know that in English
in this kind of construction
the first word is going to
be the agent, the one who's
doing the thing.
And the third word is going to
be the patient, the one who's
receiving the doing.
And that's just built
into your language system,
that you know that implicitly.
There's also the
pragmatics of language.
That is, how we understand
what somebody actually
means when they say
something to us,
which isn't always
just a function
of the actual string of words
coming out of their mouth.
So if somebody says it will be
awesome if you pass the salt,
it's not all that
awesome to have the salt.
It really means,
please pass the salt.
The pragmatics of the situation
tells you the actual intent.
And so to do pragmatics
involves thinking
about the other person's intent,
what are they thinking, what
do they want, what's
going on in their head,
and using all that
background knowledge
to constrain what do they mean
by this particular utterance.
So let's just survey
of the main pieces
of what we mean by language.
But for the next
two lectures, we're
going to focus on
the core, which
is syntax and semantics,
this stuff in here.
And I will sloppily
use the word "language"
to refer to this stuff,
not all the other stuff.
And we'll focus really on
the sentence understanding.
So what do we want to know
about sentence understanding?
Well, the first thing we want
to know is, is it even a thing.
Is language a thing separate
from the rest of thought?
Second thing we want to know
is, if it is at least something
of kind of a thing,
does language itself
have component
structure within it?
Are there different parts
of the language system
that maybe do different things?
And if so, what is
represented and computed
in each of those parts?
And third, how do we represent
meaning in the brain?
So these are the things we'll
address over the next two
lectures.
And let's start
with this question
that'll probably take up
the bulk of this lecture.
Is language distinct
from the rest of thought?
Another way of putting
this, a more familiar way,
is to ask, what is the
relationship between language
and thought?
Or even more pointedly, could
you think without language?
Probably, every one
of you has wondered
about that at some point.
So take like two or
three minutes, talk
to your neighbors about this,
see if you can figure out
whether you can think
without language,
and then let's
pool your insights.
Talk, think.
[SIDE CONVERSATIONS]
NANCY KANWISHER: OK, if
you guys all nailed it,
I'm sure you solve
the whole thing.
People have been talking about
this for probably millennia.
So, what do you guys think?
What were some of your
reflections on this question?
Come on, you guys.
Yes, Carly?
AUDIENCE: I said
I think that they
could think without language
because of like we talked
previously about how
[INAUDIBLE] babies
are given very complex thought.
But, like, he was arguing
that the whale research,
there's also the thing
that babies kind of form
their own language that
we don't understand,
but I don't think [INAUDIBLE].
NANCY KANWISHER: Not really.
If you take three-month-old
babies-- not really.
So perfect, absolutely,
you can hear this.
Babies can think.
You take 9.85,
you'll learn more.
They can really think
about all kinds of stuff.
It's really amazing how
much they understand.
And at three to six months,
there's little or no language.
So there's a beautiful case
of thinking without language.
Yeah, David?
AUDIENCE: On the
other side, if you
don't give a name to something,
if you don't give it word
to something, then it's
hard to really know it.
Like, maybe there are
20 different types
of the color green.
And if you don't decide
to call one of them
olive and another
one khaki green
or something like that, then--
NANCY KANWISHER: Then you
can't see the difference?
AUDIENCE: Well, well, I
don't know if you'd ever
think of the difference.
NANCY KANWISHER: OK,
let's think about this.
Do you think could
see the difference?
Suppose I held up an olive
patch and a khaki patch to you.
And for whatever reason, you
had been raised with deprivation
of the words olive and khaki.
AUDIENCE: But somehow it's
not about just a perception
question.
It's about remembering.
NANCY KANWISHER:
Yeah, bingo, bingo.
So that's roughly what
the literature shows.
Anya, help me out here.
I forgot to look this up.
The literature still show
that perceptually you can
discriminate them just fine.
It doesn't make a
damn bit of difference
if you have words for it.
But if you have to remember it--
sorry.
AUDIENCE: Faster.
NANCY KANWISHER: Faster, faster.
But accuracy in D
prime, I don't think
is different,
maybe a little bit.
Oops, caught.
I meant to look this up.
I knew this is going to come up.
Write me an email to
look this up and help
me find the relevant stuff.
Anyway, doesn't make a huge
difference perceptually,
but it does if you have
to remember it for later.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: That's actually what
I say because I'm actually
reproducing the
experiment that found
that there was a difference
in color [INAUDIBLE]..
NANCY KANWISHER: Aha, aha.
What?
In perception or memory?
AUDIENCE: So they found that--
I believe it was--
NANCY KANWISHER: Because there's
been a long history with this.
They find one thing and
they-- that's partly why I'm--
AUDIENCE: It's like a
difference in the reaction time.
Interesting enough, they
found that if they introduce
interference in their
linguistic system,
then that difference went away.
So that's evidence
that the language
is causing the difference.
NANCY KANWISHER: And that's in
a perceptual discrimination.
OK.
AUDIENCE: It's pretty small.
NANCY KANWISHER: Yeah, yeah,
well, behavioral, well, yeah,
effects often are.
Yeah, Isabel?
AUDIENCE: I remember one of
the first neuroscience talks I
went to in college was a woman
who had been [INAUDIBLE]..
She got in a terrible
stroke and she's
suffering from aphasia
[INAUDIBLE] the speaking part
and forgot all the
language she learned.
It took over her over a
year to regain [INAUDIBLE]..
And I remember the
question that I asked was,
you have this really
terrible pain [INAUDIBLE]..
But what did your
inner voice sound like?
And she said, well, I don't
really have one, [INAUDIBLE]..
And then she said,
well, I must have
thought in images and feelings.
And the interesting
thing that I experienced
when I was relearning to talk
was that, the more English
I learned, the more my
thoughts was with grammar.
So I still could
have these thoughts,
but they were formulated
in a different way
than they were when
I had [INAUDIBLE]
the structured
language department.
NANCY KANWISHER:
OK, that's great.
So we're going to learn more
about all of that, absolutely.
OK, very good.
So cool question, not obvious.
Let's see what the data say.
So first of all, you
guys talked about babies
and how they can think.
But animals can think too, maybe
not fully as richly as we can,
but they can think in all
kinds of subtle, rich ways.
And animals don't have language.
And so that's another
case, animals and infants.
And I'm mentioning
numerosity because these
are things we happen to
have mentioned in here.
Remember, the approximate
number system.
Animals are great at that.
Very young infants are
greater that when they
don't have language at all.
Also, by the way,
people whose language
do not have any number
words whatsoever
can do approximate numerosity.
So here's a cool study from Ted
Gibson's lab a few years ago.
They went down into
remote parts of the Amazon
to study this group
of people, the Piraha.
Here they are in their canoe.
They are a hunter-gatherer tribe
of just a few hundred people.
Their language is, as
far as linguists can
tell, unrelated to anyone else.
And it has no number words.
There's a whole
dispute about that,
but the current view
is there are really
no number words at all,
not even for zero or one.
So how do they do at
approximate magnitude?
Well, let's see.
So here is the testing
session down in the Amazon.
And this is the experimenter
lining up a bunch of, I think,
they're batteries.
And this guy is asked to
match the number of balloons
to the number of batteries.
And he has to do it aligned
this way so he can't just
put them one next to the other.
If you let him, he'll put
them one next to the other.
But this is designed
to test it better.
And he puts down four balloons.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[SIDE CONVERSATIONS]
Bingo, very good.
OK, no number words
in his language.
What about this case?
- Hi, people.
NANCY KANWISHER: Oh,
the plot is thickening.
- Six or five, [INAUDIBLE]
- [INAUDIBLE] lot of thread.
[INAUDIBLE] of thread.
NANCY KANWISHER: He laughs,
he thinks that's pretty funny.
But watch.
- Five, five.
NANCY KANWISHER:
[? Valiant ?] goes ahead.
- [INAUDIBLE] I think
it is [INAUDIBLE] five.
Lots, lots.
[INAUDIBLE] and intensifier,
like lots and lots.
- You're doing well.
NANCY KANWISHER:
Right, right, right.
- There you go.
- Good.
- You can see which one.
- Nine-- nine, 10.
- 10?
That was 10?
[END PLAYBACK]
NANCY KANWISHER: So I
think he gave nine for 10,
or something like that.
Anyway, if I had any of
you guys do this task
and I prevented
you from counting
by having you do verbal
shadowing or something else
to tie up your
language system, you
would do exactly the
same as this guy does.
So the approximate number
system doesn't require language,
doesn't require number
words in your language
to get the concept.
And it doesn't require use
of language to do the task.
AUDIENCE: He saw
him put [INAUDIBLE]??
NANCY KANWISHER: Sorry?
AUDIENCE: He actually
saw him put all of them?
He saw?
NANCY KANWISHER:
Yeah, just like you--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
NANCY KANWISHER: I mean, that's
the actual experiment being
conducted right there.
OK, so we've just argued that
at least the approximate number
system is present in animals
who don't have number words,
infants who don't, and adults
who don't have number words.
What about other
aspects of thought?
And what can we learn from
studying brain disorders,
as Isabel mentioned a moment
ago, a very rich source.
So here's the question
we're considering.
We're taking language and
thought, or cognition,
and we're asking whether they're
totally separate in the mind
and brain or whether they're
totally the same thing
or whether there's some
relationship that they're
somewhat different.
So that's the question.
What do we learn
from brain disorders?
Well, let's start with
developmental disorders.
And there are unfortunately
a large number of these.
For example, there
are language savants,
people with Down syndrome,
Williams syndrome,
Turner syndrome.
These are all
developmental disorders
in which people have
very low IQs, but,
notably, in each of these
cases, very good language.
Perhaps the most striking
is Williams syndrome.
These kids are remarkable.
They have very low IQs.
They can't do the most basic
spatial reasoning tasks.
They can't cross
the street safely.
They can't live
independently at all.
And yet they're highly social.
And their language is almost
indistinguishable from any
of yours.
Not quite-- if you
test them subtly,
can find some differences,
but it is rich and complex.
And it's bizarre.
Because you'd think if
your thoughts are so
impoverished because
your IQ is low,
how could you have
rich language.
But that's the weird thing
about Williams syndrome.
Their language is extremely
rich and, in fact,
poetic and quite
beautiful and expressive.
So that's really
surprising and suggests
that you can have quite severely
impaired cognition and very
good language.
So that's the first crack
that these things are
more separate than you'd guess.
Actually, I find this one more
surprising than all the others.
But in cases of
brain damage, which
was the first mental function
localized in the brain.
So this is
historically important.
Way back in 1861,
Paul Broca stood up
in front of the Anthropology
Society of Paris
and he announced that
the left frontal lobe
was the seat of speech.
And this is on the basis
of his patient Tan, who
had a big nasty
lesion right there
in what became known
as Broca's area.
Tan was his name because,
after that lesion, that was all
he could say.
So this is back when
the mainstream view
was very much against
localization of function
in the brain.
There were people like
Franz Josef Gall who
were going around saying that
different parts of the brain
did very different things,
but Gall was kind of a nut
and he was not taken seriously
by the academic elite,
whereas Broca was a fancy
member of the French academic
societies and a muckety muck.
And when he announced that
the left frontal lobe is
the seat of speech, everybody
had to pay attention.
So it was big stuff.
Importantly, Broca noted that
Tan wasn't globally impaired
at thinking, that Tan could
do all kinds of things,
even though he could not speak.
So he was already onto this
critical idea way back in 1861.
And he's just the most
famous in that group.
There were a bunch of people
before him in the decades
before who were reporting
similar kinds of associations.
So what would it be like to have
intact thought despite impaired
language?
So Isabel mentioned, asking
somebody who had a stroke.
OK, Great.
So here's another case.
This is a case of this
guy here, Tom Lubbock,
who died a few years
ago from a brain tumor
in his temporal lobe that
destroyed most of his language,
but it destroyed it gradually.
And this guy was a writer.
He was an art critic for
a major English paper.
And as he started to lose
language, he wrote about it,
and he wrote about
it very beautifully.
And he said, "my language to
describe things in the world
is very small, limited.
My thoughts when I
look at the world
are vast, limitless, and normal.
Same as they ever were.
My experience of
the world is not
made less by lack of language
but is essentially unchanged."
So that's a very powerful and
surprising piece of writing.
It's a little bit
mysterious, because here's
this guy writing
beautifully and telling us
his language is impaired.
So his idea of language
impairment may not be mine.
I wish I could write that well.
Nonetheless, he's
clearly reflecting
on what is a very big loss of
his previous language ability.
And I'm sure it was very
painstaking to write
these sentences.
And he's still telling
us that, even though he's
lost a lot of language, it has
not changed his experience.
So that's just one
subjective impression.
So that argues against
this extreme view
that they're the same thing,
but it leaves a lot of slop.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
because he had a [INAUDIBLE]
of speaking and learning
about the word before.
NANCY KANWISHER: Yes.
A very important point.
Absolutely.
So this is a case
of somebody who
had a lesion in mid-life
40, 50, something like that.
He had a whole lifetime of using
language to learn and bootstrap
all of cognition.
So absolutely we
have to separate
two different questions.
Do you need language to become a
normal, intelligent, functional
human being?
Do you need it
throughout development?
Or, once you've developed, do
you still need it to think?
And those are two very
different questions.
And, in fact, absolutely you
need language to develop.
If you reflect for a moment
on all the things you know,
take a quick mental inventory,
survey all the things you know,
it's a lot of things, almost
all of those you learned
because somebody told you.
Most of what we know
we learn from language.
Maybe you read about it.
But that's somebody telling
you in a different way.
So language is crucial for
development of cognition
and for learning.
Absolutely.
But now we're asking
a different question
of whether you need
it, whether it's
the same thing in adulthood.
So this guy is a
little bit complicated,
because he obviously still
has a lot of language left.
Let's consider
cases of people who
have essentially no language
due to brain damage.
So this is known
as global aphasia.
And Rosemary Varley in
England has been studying
a group of three people--
I think she's got a
few more, but here
are her three main ones--
who have global aphasia.
And she's been studying
them for a few years.
And, sorry, it doesn't
show here at all.
Sorry about this
lousy projector.
Shows on my screen.
They're big, nasty,
lesions taking up
a lot of the left
hemisphere and basically
knocking out essentially
all the language regions
in these three individuals.
And here's their performance on
a bunch of different language
tasks.
They have to look at
a picture and name it.
They have to understand
reversible sentences.
That's like boy kiss girl
versus girl kiss boy.
They need to know
who did the kissing
and who got kissed, right,
and a whole bunch of questions
like that.
And they are at chance
at every one of these.
So these are people-- not
just people who can't speak.
They're people who can't
speak or understand
language pretty much at all.
So it's as close as we can
get to a case of a person who
has no language ability.
So can these people think?
So Rosemary Varley
has done paper
after paper in which she finds
clever ways to communicate
tasks to these people to find
out what kind of thinking
they're capable of.
Here's one.
You have to order this
series of pictures.
So look at it for
a second and you
can figure out that it goes
basically from to left.
So can people with global
aphasia do this task?
Yes, they're perfect at
it, no problem whatsoever.
Now you might dispute,
is that cause and effect.
Is it knowledge of sequences?
Are they different?
I don't know.
But anyway, it's a
pretty rich task here.
Here's another task.
Look at these pictures
and tell which
of them are things
you know and which
of them are things you have
never seen before that I drew.
Takes a moment, but
you can figure it out.
Top three things
are real things,
and those three things
are things I drew.
So we could ask, does a
person with globalization
know the difference.
Basically, do you have
to be able to name
things to know the difference
of what's a real thing
and what's not?
Here's another task.
Which of these is
the plausible event?
That's more complicated, because
here we just need to know,
is that a real
thing that I know.
Here we need to know,
who's doing what to who,
and does it make sense?
So it taps world
knowledge, figuring out
who's doing what to whom,
which many people think
is at the core of language.
So how do people with
global aphasia do?
Perfectly at both
of these things.
Well, not perfectly, but the
same as control subjects.
Yeah, Carly?
AUDIENCE: I'm just confused.
Like, how do you
get the question
across what they need to do?
NANCY KANWISHER: I
don't know exactly,
but you do something
like, for example.
Do you ever play charades?
Like that.
AUDIENCE: So, like,
it's not exactly--
couldn't someone
argue that there's
actions that you're doing or
some kind of form of language?
NANCY KANWISHER:
They're communication.
They're not language.
So when we say language,
we really mean language.
Not necessarily
noises coming out of
the mouth, because American
Sign Language counts.
And I didn't have time to put
that in this lecture, which
is a damn shame, because it
really does count in every way
and is very interesting and
uses similar neural structures
and all that stuff.
But language is different
than communication.
There's all kinds of
ways of communicating.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: And how old
are these patients again?
NANCY KANWISHER: I
don't know exactly,
but it's almost always strokes.
They're probably 40 to 60.
AUDIENCE: So it's
definitely an adult.
I mean, it's not a infant thing.
NANCY KANWISHER: No, no, no.
These are all people who
had brain damage in midlife
or later in life.
So that's pretty impressive, OK.
So, basically, these
people with global aphasia
are able to do every single
task that Rosemary Varley has
tested them on.
So I just showed you
causality, nonverbal meaning.
Here's a cool one.
Remember reorientation--
you should.
May well be on the final exam.
To remind you, I did a
whole most of a lecture
on this thing about
reorientation.
Remember, rats and infants,
if you hide food there and put
them in this box, they later
go 50-50 to the two corners,
even though that wall
should disambiguate which
is the exactly correct corner.
They should always go here.
They have the knowledge that
it's there, but they go 50-50.
And, remember, I
said that Liz Spelke
has this interesting argument
that the key thing you
need to be able to solve
that task is language.
Because, in fact,
if you test adults
and you tie up their
language system,
they behave like
infants and rats.
But if you don't tie up
their language system,
they can do the task, which is
pretty suggestive that language
is a crux of the matter.
However, the global aphasic
do this task just fine.
So now, we have to go to
[? Min ?] Young's hypothesis,
which is that maybe the role
of language in reorientation
is learning about that
whole spatial system
during childhood, which the
global aphasics could do,
not maintaining the ability
once you've gained it.
All right, they can do--
I won't give you all
the data on this--
but they can do
arithmetic tasks,
logic tasks, algebra tasks.
They appreciate music.
They can think about what
other people are thinking.
So everything that all
that kind of high level
abstract quintessentially
human abilities
that we are impressed with
ourselves for being able to do,
these people can do
without language.
So language and thought
are not the same thing.
You can still think in
lots of different ways,
even after you lose language.
On the other hand, as has
already been brought up,
global aphasics had
language during development.
So saying that you don't
need it as an adult is not
the same as saying you don't
need it during development.
You absolutely do need
it during development,
because it's a key way
we learn about the world.
And for example, there are
studies from Rebecca Sachs' lab
showing that deaf kids
who learn language later--
for example, if they're
born not to deaf parents
but to hearing parents who
don't cotton on to the fact
that it's important for
them to learn ASL early,
and hence they don't get
language until later,
those kids are not as
good at understanding
what other people are thinking,
something that we usually
learn about through language.
Further, even though
I'm making a big deal
about how you can
think without language,
I'm not saying that language
is irrelevant to thinking.
Every time I write
a grant proposal,
I think, oh god, I have
all these ideas in my head
and now I have to
waste weeks and weeks
and weeks, blah, blah,
blah, putting them
all down on paper to try to
get money to fund my habit.
And then I get into
like sentence 3
and I suddenly
realize, oh, oh no, I
haven't been thinking
about this clearly at all.
So this is my very
informal introspection
on the role of language
in my own thinking.
Like, even when I think
there's a clear thought,
the same thing happens when
I go to prepare a lecture.
It's, like, oh yeah,
I know this stuff.
But I put together some
slides, I'm like slide 2,
no, I don't really
know this stuff.
So there is some role for
language and thinking.
And I'll give you
one example here.
One of the many things
that language can do
is to make information
more salient.
So right now, close your eyes,
everyone close your eyes.
I mean it, I see
if they're open.
While keeping your eyes
closed, point south.
You may not exactly
know where south
is, but make a good guess.
Use your whole arm
so everyone can
see when they open their eyes.
Keep pointing, but now
you can open your eyes
and you can look
around and see where
everyone else is pointing.
You guys are not bad,
not bad, not bad.
But we got some over here, we're
a little turned around here.
Anyway, it's roughly over there.
So, yeah, hang
on, wait a second.
Yes, right.
Well, hang on.
Yeah, right, it's over there.
So your vector
average was closer
to the true thing than a
random vector, but not so hot.
If your language forced
you to keep track of this,
you'd be better at it.
And we know that from the
case of the Pormpuraaw,
these guys here, who
live in Australia.
It's Aboriginal people.
And they spend a lot
of time going around
in the remote
outback of Australia,
where they need to
know where they are.
And who is going where
and when is really
of the essence in
their lives and
in their social interactions.
So when they run
into each other,
they don't say, hi, how are you.
Instead, they say,
which way are you going.
And a typical answer
might be, "North northwest
in the middle distance,
how about you?"
They don't talk about
things being left or right
or behind them,
reference frames that
have to do with the person's
own body, which are frankly
really stupid reference frames.
Because I can say this
thing is to the left.
And then I turn, and now
it's not to the left anymore.
Like, how stupid is that, right?
These guys have a
much better system.
They would rather
say, oh, "You have
a bug on your southeast leg."
Right, OK.
So these guys, people
who speak this language,
they have to be aware of
absolute compass directions
all the time just to speak.
And so they're oriented
all the time, unlike us.
And in that sense,
their language
makes salient certain
kinds of information.
It's not that we can't
think about direction.
It's just that most of
the time we're not aware
because our language doesn't
force us to think about it.
So interim summary.
We've been asking this
question of whether thought
is separate from and
possible without language.
Before you guys take
off, you wrote it
on the board, this
board right here?
Awesome.
You guys need to tell me when
there's time to take the quiz.
So you're going to have
seven minutes because there's
seven questions.
And so at 12:18 let me know and
I will turn the board around.
OK, 12:17 because it'll take
me a minute to turn around.
All right, thank you.
Take notes, tell
me about that time.
So here's a question
we've been engaging in,
is thought separate from and
possible without language?
And the literature from
neuroscience psych patients
says, yes, absolutely,
they're totally separate.
Global aphasics have many forms
of thought without language.
So given that, what would you
predict from functional MRI?
So if I told you, which is
true, that these are the brain
regions that are active
during language tasks,
for example, when you understand
the meaning of a sentence,
what would you predict?
Should they be activated
only by language, not
by non-linguistic tasks?
What do you think?
Take a moment to think about it.
These are the regions that are
engaged when you understand
the meaning of a sentence.
Would you expect them to be
engaged based on what I've just
told you when you do
mental arithmetic, when
you think about
spatial orientations,
when you appreciate music?
No, right.
If they're separate,
they're separate.
They should go on in
different brain regions.
Everybody have that intuition?
No, you don't have
that intuition?
AUDIENCE: No.
I mean, do you think about
things in terms of words,
even as a mental crutch,
even if you didn't have to?
NANCY KANWISHER: OK,
fair enough, fair enough.
So it doesn't nail this case.
It could well be that you
have separate systems for all
those other things, but you
still lean on the system.
Not necessarily, but
you use it sometimes.
In fact, there's
evidence for that
that we won't get to today.
But the initial thought is,
you don't need to activate it.
Well, here's a surprise.
Up until recently, pretty
much the whole brain imaging
literature says that
language overlaps
with all of these
things in the brain,
that the activations
overlap in the brain.
They're all the same thing.
That's been the received
story for 20 years or so
of brain imaging.
And that just does not fit
with the patient literature.
So we have a conundrum.
Here are just a few examples.
Stan Dehaene says, "arithmetic
recruits networks involved
in word association processes."
People who study
music say regions
such as Broca's area
and Wernicke's area,
which have been considered
specific to language,
are also activated by
certain aspects of music.
Thus, the idea of
language specificity
has been called into
question, and on and on.
There's a million of these.
I just put a few
of them up there.
So what's going on.
How are we going to
resolve this contradiction?
On the one hand, the
patient literature
suggests that language
is separate from the rest
of thought.
And on the other hand, most
of the neuroimaging literature
says that if you look at
those language regions,
you find them activated in all
these other kinds of things.
One hypothesis is David's,
that they're activated but not
essentially so.
But there's another hypothesis.
And that is that there's a
methodological flaw with most
of the prior research.
What is that
methodological flaw?
It's an inappropriate
use of something
called a group analysis.
I've alluded to this
a few times briefly,
but let me do it for real now.
Let me first say, it's
not that a group analysis
with functional MRI
is an evil thing that
should never be done.
They have uses.
But particularly
for the question
of asking whether common
regions of the brain
are engaged in two
different tasks,
it is not a good method,
for the following reason.
So, first, let's say,
what is a group analysis.
With functional
MRI, it just means--
and, again, I'm going to
be very sketchy with this
because this is not an actual
hands-on methods class.
I'm just trying to
get you to understand
the gist of the methods.
You take a bunch
of scanned brains
and you align them in a
common space as best you can.
You can't do it
perfectly because brains
are anatomically different
from one person to the next.
But you do your best to
align them as best you can.
Then you do an analysis
across those aligned brains.
And you ask, what is consistent
across this group of subjects.
That's a very useful
question to ask.
If we want to know overall
what are the brain regions that
are consistently activated
when you understand language
across this whole
group of subjects,
that's a good use
of a group analysis.
You'll find that picture
I just showed you
before with stuff going
down the left temporal lobe,
a bunch of left
frontal lobe stuff.
And that will be a
very blurry picture
of the regions that are most
consistent across subjects.
Yes, [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: Do you line
them anatomically
as you new [INAUDIBLE]
side to each other?
Or do you line
them functionally,
so you can look at the scans
in the functional [? region? ?]
NANCY KANWISHER: So therein
lies a universe of options.
What I'm talking about
now is a group analysis
is aligning them anatomically.
And that's where the
problem comes in.
And where we're going
to go from that is you
need to align them functionally.
If you just align
them anatomically,
then the following can happen.
So you do a standard
group analysis
and you say, for example,
let's do a language task
and arithmetic task
and a music task.
And let's suppose
you find this--
basically, Broca's area vicinity
is activated in an overlapping
fashion in all three.
Each of those is based on an
analysis of 12 or 20 subjects
aligned as best we can.
So that's basically what
the literature shows
is lots of stuff like that.
But here's the problem.
You can get that result
in a group analysis,
even if the actual
data looks like this
in each individual subject.
No overlap at all
in any subject,
but those regions are in
slightly different locations.
And so if you average
across this, you get that.
Everybody see the problem?
So it's not that it's a bad
idea to do a group analysis.
It's a nice, initial,
blurry picture
of the approximate
consistent locations
in the brain for a given task.
The problem is when you
say, oh, there's overlap,
therefore they're
the same thing,
because you can get
this result even
if there's no overlap
in any subject at all.
So the whole literature
did this for 20 years
and made all this talk
about how language
is on top of everything
else in the brain.
And for a long time I was
sitting by the sidelines
going, oh my god.
And then, eventually,
Ev Fedorenko came along
and she knew about language.
And I said, let's figure
out, maybe they're right,
maybe that's true, or
maybe it's like this.
Let's find out.
So how do we do that?
What you do is exactly
what [INAUDIBLE]
mentioned a moment ago.
You align them not
anatomically but functionally.
That's a whole reason to use
functional reasons of interest.
We've encountered this
before when I was carrying on
about why we do functional
localizers with the fusiform
face area.
This is the same deal.
It's just that that insight
started in the back of the head
and hasn't reached the
front of the head yet,
or it's about here.
So some people get it here.
And the farther forward you
go, the less people realize
this is an issue, which
is really ridiculous,
because it gets more and more
important as you go this way.
Some stuff is actually
aligned in the back
and nothing is
aligned in the front.
Anyway, so what do you do?
You do just what we did with the
FFA and all the other regions.
One, in each subject
individually,
you identify those
language regions.
You run some localizer.
It's like, OK, I got
this and that and that.
And then once you
identified them,
you can ask, OK, does that
region in that subject
show activation for arithmetic.
No, that's next door,
right, et cetera.
Everybody got this?
This is really important.
I guess just because
I'm obsessed with it.
I honestly don't know if
it's globally important
or if it's just my
personal obsession,
but you need to know
it for this course.
We'll leave it at that.
So this is standard in
people who study vision
and it's less standard in people
who work in other domains.
But they're slowly cottoning on.
So how do we identify language
regions in each subject
individually?
There are lots of
possible ways to do this.
But here's the way
I'm going to show you
that's been used a bunch
by Fedorenko and others.
So we start by saying, OK,
let's find candidate brain
regions that respond to
language, which I told you,
by language, I mean
sentence understanding
for present purposes.
So if we want to look at
sentence understanding,
we've got to start with
sentence understanding.
So if you look at
the screen, you'll
see some of the stimuli we use.
So subject is lying in the
scanner and they see that.
And then we can either
give them a task or not.
And we'll talk about
that in a second.
What are we going
to compare it to?
Well, there are lots and
lots of different things
we could compare it to that
control for different things.
But we started off with
this, if you read this here.
So the idea is, it's
visually similar.
You can hear the
sounds in your head.
You can pronounce those
things to yourself.
But there's really no
syntax and no meaning--
not perfect, but a first pass.
So when you do that,
you get activations
that look like this.
Here are four
different subjects.
And you can see they're
very systematic things.
See these three blobs--
boom, boom, boom,
boom, boom, boom--
in each subject, and a bunch
of stuff in the temporal lobe
like that in each subject.
They're quite systematic but
absolutely not identical.
All right, so, yeah,
it's just what I did.
So now what do you do next?
Well, we just made
this up, sentences
versus non-word strings.
Well, who says that's
a good thing to do?
So the next thing
you do is you've
got to validate your localizer
task to make sure it isn't just
like trivial in some sense.
So the first question
is, is it reliable?
So, here's session 1,
three different subjects'
activations.
Well, just scan them again.
There's a lot of talk about
fancy statistics, blah, blah
blah.
Just scan them again.
Wow, look how similar
these two little hot spots,
this elongated one.
I mean, it's
remarkable, extremely
reliable within a
subject, and yet somewhat
different across subjects,
so check one, reliable.
More interestingly, does
it generalize across task
and presentation modality?
So before we just had
people reading sentences.
And I keep saying,
reading is not
the native form of language.
So let's replicate that reading.
And now we're adding
a memory task.
So at the end of each string,
a little probe comes up and you
have to say, was this word
or a non-word in the previous
thing--
sequence.
And let's compare that to just
listening to the sentences.
Wow, look how similar.
So that tells us that we're
not studying reading or speech.
We're studying language
after those things converge.
Those regions don't care if you
saw a word or heard the word.
They just care if
you're representing
the meaning of a sentence.
Everybody with me
why that's important?
All right, check, check.
Does it generalize
across languages?
Suppose you're bilingual and
speak two different languages.
Here's two subjects who speak
both English and Spanish.
Wow, look how similar.
So it's really
language in general,
not English or Spanish
or a particular language.
Does it generalize
across materials?
So we could have reading
sentences versus non-words
that we've been talking
about here with two
different runs in one subject.
Are we going have
subjects listening
to speech versus degraded
speech, like this?
Here's the speech case.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- During my days
of house arrest,
it felt as though I were no
longer part of the real world.
NANCY KANWISHER:
OK, versus this.
- [INAUDIBLE]
[END PLAYBACK]
NANCY KANWISHER: OK,
so very degraded.
You can't understand
what's being said,
but it has similar prosody
and some similar structure.
And the point is, you get
very similar activations
with those very different
kinds of contrasts.
So now we have really
validated this thing.
It checks out in all
the ways it should.
It doesn't care about modality.
It does care about meaning.
And it's highly reliable.
So now we can put it to use.
Now we can ask, what does
each of those regions do?
All right, so to do
that, in each participant
then we find those regions
with this localizer.
Now let me just
step back a second.
There's nothing magic about
this localizer per se.
When you want to
study something,
you use common sense.
You try something,
you validate it.
It may turn out later that
of the thing that we thought
we were identifying language
with this localizer,
it's got this other stuff.
And then maybe you
refine your localizer
into something different.
So it's not that this is
the only possible way.
It was just a sensible approach.
So you use this to
find those regions.
Here they are in
these four subjects.
And now, you can
say, let's find.
So you have to
figure out some way
to say that thing corresponds
to that to that to that.
And there's a
whole bunch of math
that was invented to do that.
You can basically see
it with your eyeballs
that those guys roughly
correspond and those guys
roughly correspond.
The math is just
a way to do that.
And then once you've
found that region,
you can measure its response in
a whole bunch of new conditions
and ask what it does.
And in particular, so this is
different from a group analysis
where you don't
identify those regions.
You just choose
regions anatomically
So if we just align them and
said, OK, that's a region,
well, we don't have much of
the language stuff there,
not much there, a lot
there, not much there.
OK, that's not great.
Then we take another
one and we define this.
This is a problem.
No language stuff
here, lots of language
stuff there, none and lots.
Not good.
Everybody see how
that's a problem?
OK, I guess I'm flogging this.
We can move on now.
But the main problems
with the group analysis
are you might fail to detect
neural activity that's actually
there, because it doesn't align
well enough across subjects
and so it doesn't
reach threshold.
It's not consistent.
But for present purposes,
the more relevant problem
is, you might fail to
distinguish between two
different functions,
because they
invariably coexist within
that region or not.
So we're not doing that
for present purposes.
Instead, we're
going to now go back
to the conundrum of why do
the patient studies suggest
that language is distinct
from the rest of thought,
but the past
functional MRI studies
suggest that language
overlaps with other functions
in the brain.
And we're going to
consider the hypothesis
that if you study
individual brains
and localize those regions
individually in each subject,
then the story
might be different.
And it is.
So here's the task
that Fedorenko and I
did a few years ago.
We came up with seven
different tasks.
I won't bore you
with all the details.
It doesn't really matter.
We just had lots of stuff,
arithmetic, spatial working
memory, various
cognitive control tasks,
working memory tests,
all kinds of stuff,
focusing on things that--
music, focusing on stuff
that other people
had said overlaps
with language in the brain.
And so first thing
is you've got to make
sure those other tasks
actually produce activations,
because it's easy to make up a
task and have it not do much,
and then that's not
very interesting.
So, yes, each one of those tasks
produce lots of activation.
Look at all that red stuff.
Looks like a bunch of pizzas.
So they produce
good activations.
Now the question is, do
those activations overlap
with the language regions.
So let's consider two of them.
This is basically
Wernicke's area
and Broca's area, two
well-known language regions,
identified individually
in each subject
and now averaging the response
over all the conditions.
Here's a response
when subjects read
sentences and non-word strings,
sentences and non-word strings.
That's how we define
those regions,
but this is in data
that wasn't actually
used to define those regions.
We held out some data and
just cross-validated it.
Now the question is, how
do those regions respond
to all of these other things?
They don't, pretty much at all.
So notice what's happened here.
The prior literature
shows massive overlap
between language and
all these other things.
In our data, when you identify
those language regions
in each subject
individually and measure
the magnitude of response
in those other things,
they don't respond.
So this shows stunning
specificity of the language
regions consistent
with the picture that
comes from the
patient literature,
from studies of brain damage.
Language really is
separate in the brain
from all of these things
Everybody get that picture?
And the reason the
literature had it wrong
is they were mushing brains
together and blurring
the hell out of their data
and drawing wrong conclusions.
I'm speeding up because I
don't want to run out of time.
So we started with
these questions here.
Is language distinct
from the rest of thought?
I'm saying, yes, language may
be necessary to learn to think.
And it is indeed.
But the evidence from
the neurological patients
is pretty powerful.
Global aphasics with
pretty much no language
can think in myriad,
sophisticated ways.
And when you do your
functional MRI studies right,
you find that the language
regions in the brain,
in fact, are not active during
non-linguistic thinking.
Make sense?
Questions?
Wow, I finished on time.